so that means we have time to bring up
another chess game a very special
tweet came out earlier today it's uh I
actually got a message it's a tweet that
has already gotten for 14.5 million
likes on Cristiano Ronaldo's Twitter
page it's this picture of Lionel Messi
and Cristiano Ronaldo playing a chess
game on top of a Louis Vuitton suitcase
a checkered suitcase how cool of a
picture is that and of course the moment
we saw this we thought wait what kind of
a game are they playing are they playing
an actual chess game and David you took
a look at this what do you think yes it
is an actual game it's taken from a real
life game between the two greatest chess
players in the world these are the two
greatest footballers uh playing right
now for sure this is a game between
Magnus Carlson and Hikaru Nakamura from
Norway chess 2017. we had to zoom in we
had to work out which pieces were on
which squares
um it's slightly confusing the
dimensions but uh this was from a real
game and it looks like it's black to
play in the position so it's Messi's
move uh Messi is black Ronaldo is white
in this position and as we saw in that
game between Carlson and Nakamura the
messian Ronaldo of chess it did end up
in a draw so here white has an extra
Bishop white would be winning the game
if it's his move if it's white to play
the Queen will step forward uh hitting
the black king but uh the game did end
with a draw the black queen gave a came
across gave a check the black queen
stepped back and the checks continued no
way to escape for petrol check so it's
very fitting between Ronaldo and Messi
the two greatest players in the world uh
greatest footballers it was a draw and
how cool that when they did this photo
shoot
they found an actual chess game and they
decided to to make it a chess game
between
Magnus and Hikaru whose idea do you
think it was Ronaldo maybe he's met
Magnus several times quite possibly uh I
remember Magnus uh kicking off at some
Real Madrid matches when Ronaldo was
there maybe that was an inside joke
between them maybe they just thought oh
we're the two greatest footballers of
our time who are the two greatest chess
players most famous chess players of
that time I think that would be Magnus
and Hikaru I'm not sure who's who would
Magnus be Ronaldo would Hikaru be
Ronaldo wait so who was the white and
that the Magnus Hikaru game
I think magnus's I think Magnus was
white
uh we will have to get that confirmed
but Magnus was white yeah Ronaldo Magnus
Messi Nakamura I bet Cristiano Ronaldo
brought this game and said he wanted to
be white and be Magnus Carlsen
quite possible and uh yeah maybe in
future years they'll reenact a game
between Magnus and Prague two of the
greatest players of this generation
definitely yeah
[Music]
yeah that is serious mostly cool and I
love the kind of iconic Louis Vuitton
checkerboard style so it's perfect
Fusion football stars chess
baton yeah golden three beautiful